all right happy midweek glad to get the
football night guys all together florio
and i business casual tony and rodney
look like they're heading to the first
tee and we're jealous you guys look a
heck of a lot more comfortable than we
are well so we we sit down and record
this on wednesday so
for the first time i know since we've
been doing this we can talk about a game
that happened last night in a tuesday
night football game at a nice early
starting time too it's nice to watch a
football game at seven o'clock and it
was done by 10.
so rodney i'm going gonna start with you
because i was thinking man tennessee
this is so tough only one practice and
all that and buffalo looked like the
team that was kept from practicing for a
couple of weeks how surprised were you
or what tennessee did on tuesday night
mike we talked before the show i wasn't
really that surprised with um tennessee
because this is a smart football team
mike vrabel was a smart player when i
played with him and this team actually
reminds me of some of the teams that i
played on um
smart physical team plays well under
pressure
and anytime you have an opportunity to
run the football and play good defense
like they did last night you're going to
have a chance to win
and i really think this is going to be
what we're going to see going forward
you're going to see some teams who
adapt and adjust and have no excuses no
explanation mentality and you're going
to have teams that
do get caught up in schedule changes and
whatever and i think as a coach that's
what you got to get across to your
players hey i don't care when they say
we're going to play i don't care how
many times the facility gets shut down
how many different things we go through
our job is to go out there and play well
whenever that is and i think you're
going to see some teams that have that
mentality and and tennessee certainly
did
yeah mike before you jump in tony it
felt like tennessee was rodney and i
were talking about this before we
started recording
this is who we are this is what we do
and we're just gonna be able to pick up
where we left off because we don't
reinvent the wheel every week we we have
a true identity and we just play to it
and it felt like that's what i was
watching on tuesday night
absolutely and it kind of took me back
to my old days and growing up and pick
up basketball hey you want to play
let's go let's go down the playground
let's go right now and you bring your a
game whenever that is and the guys from
the east side come over hey we want to
play you let's go and and that's the
mentality i thought tennessee had
were you more point guard or a shooter
i wasn't a shooter
okay
you're distributed i just i just want to
be clear about that guy mike i'm sorry
how many times do we hear
coaches and players say they don't hear
anything from outside the building we
pay no attention to the outside noise
and yet again it's proven to be baloney
they listen to everything and they look
for anything that they can use to
motivate themselves including
all these people are saying bad things
about us for how we did or didn't comply
with the covet 19 protocols and
everybody's talking down to us and
saying that we're negligent saying that
we did this and they use that as
motivation it just shows they'll use
anything they can and credit them like
frable for getting the guys extra
stirred up because people were
questioning their compliance with
protocols of all things it's it's just
great because it shows that at the core
they're all human they get motivated by
anything they can and it can lead to
good results on the football field if it
works
rodney were you ever motivated by the
media
um i think mike florio hit it right spot
on yeah you hear everything in inside
and outside the building and it's
definitely something um to motivate you
because when everybody's saying that hey
you did this wrong or you did that wrong
um yeah it brings you together as a team
but i was really impressed with some of
the guys like khalif raymond who's been
playing really well for him um john who
smith is a guy that i've been clamoring
for to get the ball more the last couple
years he's a he's an exciting guy he can
play tight end he can play running back
he can play a multitude of uh positions
but i just like what vrable's done he's
been very consistent he's the leader he
respects his players he treats them like
men and defensively i think they're
really really underrated
before we drop this mike i'm going to
take your point to tony here for a
second tony what was the best uh use of
what they're saying about us that you
brought to motivation for your team
you know i wasn't a big uh billboard guy
or bulletin board material but i did
talk to our team a lot when they would
say we can't win the big one you guys
choke in the playoffs that kind of thing
and just really talked about it doesn't
matter if we do what we're supposed to
do and play ball we're going to win uh
people don't think you can do it it
doesn't matter what anybody else thinks
it only matters what we do in this room
well mike i can say this we use a lot of
tarico i can say this we used um coach
dungey and peyton manning in that
offense as uh a lot of bulletin board
material trust me over the years we
would always put up there
these guys are averaging 30-some points
no one can stop them look what they did
to denver in the playoffs you remember
that coach you guys man you guys are so
tough
i remember it well
true story is a little longer thing
about
last night's game
um at a time when we are seeing
quarterbacks come into the league and
right away they get it and it causes the
quarterbacks who don't get it right away
to fall out of favor and disappear ryan
tannehill good lord after all these
years of mediocrity and injury and he's
no good and remember he came into the
nfl
after playing receiver at texas a m he
was a quarterback for one year and now
he's one of the best quarterbacks in the
nfl and there's something different
about him he carries himself differently
he's got a confidence he's got a swagger
and i think people are finally waking up
to the idea that this guy's pretty darn
good
he's getting one of the best all right
go ahead go ahead coach
we we had nick foles a couple of weeks
ago uh against tom brady and nick foles
was saying
you know when i
finally got to philadelphia frank wright
figured out what i did well and that's
what we've we focused on and that made
my career and i think you've got mike
vrabel as rodney said just saying here's
what this guy does well and this is what
we're going to do and uh he is blossomed
and and everybody has confidence in him
in that tennessee organization right now
and it's great to see
and offensively you talk about when you
can turn around and hand the ball off to
a 250 pound running back and you have
deep threats like aj brown and you have
these other guys stepping up making
contributions and this is the most
complete team that he's been on so yeah
i mean of course he's playing with
confidence he feels comfortable hey if
he's off a little bit we can hand the
ball off but if he's not off we can hand
the ball off we can use play action take
shots down the field you know the
tennessee titans always have good
special teams so this is the most
complete team that ryan tannehill's as
really i think he's ever played on
and i'm sure one thing okay regarding
derek henry
there's no way rodney harrison in his
prime gets smacked down the way that
josh norman did last night i'd love to
have seen that collision at some point
well i'll tell you this mike florio i i
just felt bad because josh he's had an
unbelievable career but to get
embarrassed as you've gotten older
to get pushed down like that and that's
something that we're going to see the
next 20 years with
replays and everything but yeah just go
at his knees i mean if you're trying to
tackle a guy bigger than you and i tell
my both my boys the same thing go at
their knees everybody all these running
backs nobody wants to get hit at their
knees go at their knees wrap up and hold
on for dear life
mike that wouldn't happen to rodney
today forget 12 years ago he would not
have gone down like that i promised you
that
that's involved
all right uh so mike i'm going to start
with you because i know where tony's
going to go with this and then i'll have
tony and rodney follow
analytics and football people are going
for it on fourth down more than ever and
it really has
seen the analytics impact on decisions
take over most of the teams in the nfl
what do you hear for gm's team
presidents ownership as guys are making
more of the analytics
additions into their front office staff
and that voice is getting louder in a
lot of these decision-making rooms
you know it's funny mike zimmer said in
the aftermath of the game on sunday
night where he went for it on fourth and
short he doesn't have an analytic
analytics guy talking to him in that
moment well some coaches do john
harbaugh does i mean these folks have an
equal seat at the table when it comes to
strategizing and understanding those
elements and you know that we keep
coming back to the fact that it has its
place the best coaches are going to
include that information with everything
else that gets put in the blender and
then you have to make a decision based
on who your opponent is what the weather
is where you're playing are there fans
present are there no fans present and
every other factor so it's part of it
and it's accepted as part of it i think
sometimes maybe it's too big of a part
of it but it clearly is one of the one
of the
factors driving these big decisions that
are being made every week
and i respect mike zimmer for what he
said and and to me if you made a
decision on gut feel and you just said
hey i really don't want to give russell
wilson the ball back i don't care i'll
take my chances going forward on fourth
down great don't do it though just
because the book says to do it because
the book doesn't know who's playing
defense on the other side the book
doesn't know where your team is uh
mentally physically anything just hey
fourth and one with with three minutes
to go you're going to win 80 of the time
if you go for it makes no sense to me
you know what's going on in that game
you've got to coach the team and yes i
agree with you mike use analytics but it
can't be the end all be all
right
it's interesting it's interesting rods
because
analytics is now
putting in more of those factors than
ever before who you're playing
what's going on but it still comes down
to the coaches knowing my team isn't
playing to the analytics that were put
in my guys are tired is the analytics
factoring in that my right tackle is
hampered in some way that we can't run
the base play that we know is the right
thing against this look if we get it in
this situation so analytics is putting
in everything possible now and getting
to levels that
some fans don't really understand
because we don't hear about them
everybody's very secretive about their
analytics input but it still comes down
to that decision you can't replace the
heart you can't replace the mind you
can't replace what the coach is seeing
on the sidelines so it does need to be
balanced like you said i'm sorry rods
coach coach and i mean you've been
around your players and to me it this is
a decision based on the coach and the
head coach and the coaching staff like
what do you feel with your players are
you or do you feel like your offense is
playing well do you think your defense
is struggling um do you feel like they
have a lot of confidence i mean all
these factors to me a analytical
department should be the head coach and
along with the assistant head coach why
can't we all get together huddle and
figure out what's best for the team you
do you need some type of survey no
because it doesn't take in consideration
how people feel players have feelings
players are sometimes playing with a lot
of energy sometimes they're not playing
with a lot of energy so i think it's up
to the head coach to feel uh mike zimmer
you you just in that situation i did
have a problem because now
you go up by eight you you kick the ball
out to russell he has to go 80 yards
possibly and score and get the two-point
conversion at least give yourself a
chance i know a lot of head coaches come
in and say well we're one and three um
you know we're on the road we should
take this chance no you go for no you go
and you get up a touchdown you force
them to go 80 yards down the field
convert on a two-point conversion i see
you shaking your head coach i just
totally disagree with that your players
have played too hard and they sacrificed
too much to get to this point you can't
throw it all out the window on one play
no i i agree with you let me just finish
this up on analytics
1997
uh we're i'm coaching the tampa bay
buccaneers we have a chance to draft a
five foot eight 170 pound running back
and all the atlanta analytics said he
can't be a feature back but we took
warwick done and he became the rookie of
the year
years later i met indianapolis and we've
got the 11th pick in the draft and we
took a 511 defensive end named dwight
frenian all the analytics said too small
to take he can't be a factor in the nfl
analytics don't have all the answers
thank you well said hey mike i just want
to make one last point on this
because owners come out of the business
world for the most part
do you think that their comfort has
forced coaches to be more involved in
the analytics part because spreadsheets
and facts and data that is how a lot of
these owners made their money it's how a
lot of businesses have grown
successfully do you think that in any
way has helped this wave of analytics
that has really taken over every sports
every sports franchise in the country is
hiring analytics folks at my alma mater
syracuse we're turning out kids who are
majoring in sports analysis and sports
analytics and their departments are
cropping up at universities all over the
country we're creating this industry i
just feel like ownership feels
comfortable with it because it sings
more to the tune that they've been
singing for a long time
well and you have to justify the
expenditure in the analytics department
by using the product of the analytics
work and now this gives the coach the
safe harbor the safe harbor used to be i
did the conventional thing not the
unconventional thing so don't be mad at
me and ultimately don't fire me now the
coach says i did the thing that your
analytics department told me to do don't
blame me if it didn't work
there's always someone always someone
who has to pay for it at the end of the
day rodney let's start with you a couple
of games let's hit a few guys brown
steelers this week it's really nice that
it's october up here in the midwest it's
starting to feel a little bit cool and
the browns and the steelers has me
excited to watch football on sunday what
are your initial thoughts on that game
well just looking at pittsburgh and
looking at big ben and they're not
asking big ben to drop back and just try
to do everything by himself they're
doing a good job of getting the ball out
of his hands quickly they have so many
many young talented guys all he has to
do is get the ball to his playmakers and
and they're doing what they do i love
this clay um chase claypool he's very
versatile you can put him in the slot
he's a bigger wide receiver he can do so
many different things you can hand him
the ball off and he's a problem against
linebackers in that slot i i i like what
the pittsburgh steelers are doing on the
defensive side i will i would you know
wish that um
uh mika fitzpatrick they're free safety
no sacks no interceptions and joe hayden
they have to play a little bit better in
the secondary and try to create more
turnovers but i like what the pittsburgh
steelers are doing especially with big
ben
i like what cleveland's doing and you
and i kind of had a debate the other
night uh do we believe in cleveland i
talked to kevin stefanski via text uh a
couple times after the games and he's
telling me boy you wouldn't believe we
got 31 knockdowns on offense they keep
track of how many guys they knock off
their feet and this is a different
mentality than cleveland's ever had and
it's not just hey baker mayfield's going
to go back and throw all these balls to
our great wide receivers no they they're
a complete offense and they're playing
with confidence i think it's going to be
a great game i'm looking forward to it
and cody keep going
go ahead
good rodney first go ahead florio i'm
sorry go ahead florio
all i was gonna say is this it's meeting
137 between the two teams the steelers
are up 74-59 with one tie from a couple
of years ago it feels more lopsided than
that over the years because the browns
have been so bad
i think on paper the browns are better
than pittsburgh right now the steelers
four wins have not come against great
teams and all four games have been close
the browns have been more impressive and
it's it's like you have to rewire your
brain to think of it that way because
it's always been this vibe that the
steelers are superior steelers may be in
for a surprise on sunday
we'll all i'll say we'll see we'll see
and and that and probably that that's my
biggest question about cleveland coach
if they can't run the ball do you trust
baker mayfield can take him up and down
the field like he's tried to do in the
past without the running game
well i i don't know the answer to that
question but i'll go back to what my old
coach used to say coach noel if you can
run the ball which cleveland can do and
you can rush the passer you can win a
lot of games so they've got some
elements that'll help them now what
happens if their run game gets shut down
uh that remains to be seen but i like
where cleveland is right now
i want to do more conversation on
stefanski with you down the line because
i think it's fascinating tony the way
he's come in there managed some big
personalities and big expectations and
really has them in a position to have
true impact games here in october and on
into november uh another game the
packers are playing the bucks so mike uh
when we're starting to see the whole
impact of tom brady in tampa i think
we're starting to see it now in the
games he's played brees now he plays
rogers he'll play brees again here in a
few weeks it's kind of setting the stage
for some of those big marquee
quarterback matchups that we're not
going to get many more of considering
the age of these guys
yeah absolutely we've got so many great
young quarterbacks and old quarterbacks
and the old quarterbacks who knows how
much time they have left but aaron
rodgers and tom brady used to be once
every four years they're in the same
conference now we get to see them in the
in the regular season we may see them in
the postseason but all of a sudden this
is a huge game for the buccaneers after
what happened in chicago that's a game
they should have won up 13 nothing had
the chance to drive the ball late tom
brady makes the mental mistake he's
going to be extra driven the question is
is he at the point in his career where
the spirit is willing but the flesh is
weak and we're going to see that i think
potentially when the packers start
coming after him with zadaria smith you
know he was he was vulnerable to the
outside rush we usually see tom brady
have a rough night when they're coming
at him straight up the middle we rarely
see him unable to avoid the guys who are
curling around on the outside because he
can always step up and step away but
khalil mack gave him fits
and if they can rush him consistently
from the outside they're going to have a
problem against the packers
you're right mike this is a big game i i
live down here in tampa and when tom
came uh the thought is super bowl
nobody's expecting tampa to be a 500
team and if they don't beat green bay
they're gonna be three and three and so
um
everyone is looking at this game and it
is going to come down to the
quarterbacks green bay's got a diverse
offense tampa
crowds the line of scrimmage they're not
going to let aaron jones run they've
stopped everybody running the football
this year aaron rodgers is going to have
to be spectacular to win so tom brady is
going to have to outplay aaron rodgers
in my opinion if tampa's going to win
this game and you're coming out
fireworks i think there's going to be a
lot of balls in the air
yeah it comes down to pass pressure
especially from the packers standpoint
they haven't gotten great pressure this
year at least they haven't put up big
sack numbers um zadaria smith he's
getting around a quarterback but preston
smith he struggled a little bit and this
defense to me i like this defense i
don't know where they're at as far as
you know where they rank but i think
they have a lot of talented guys they
scored a few times
on the defensive side of the football i
still like their pass rushers i think
with this offense and this offense
really taking off this defense is about
to catch up and the packers are going to
go on a really good run coach i got to
ask you this question everybody's making
a big deal about tom brady yelling and
screaming at his teammates we've known
tom for a long time
you can't make a big deal out of that
right it's just
his leadership and him trying to
motivate guys are they making a big
issue down there in tampa with tom
no they aren't here that uh bruce arians
everybody's saying that's why we got tom
brady that's what we want we want him to
lift everybody else's um
play and so they're excited about it and
i can tell you this
peyton manning has yelled at a lot of
people maybe not he didn't get caught on
camera like tom brady but uh hey those
those great quarterbacks you don't think
they they get on people uh it's probably
goes with the territory
yeah i think there's a commercial for
the microsoft surface with tom brady
throwing it with the number of times he
flips it away and then it comes back it
takes a licking and keep on tick keeps
on ticking like the old timex watches
that's pretty funny hey rodney the the
funny thing was with brady in the whole
four downs deal right we saw chase
claypool tweet out the four with the
four touchdowns we saw brady tweet out
congratulations to lebron with the four
for the fourth championship what you may
not have seen rods on saturday night i
lost track of the downs in the nordine
florida state game i said it was third
down
right away my partner right next to me
there to be no no it's second down so i
had a tom brady moment and and tony
called me out on it
that's
[Laughter]
i didn't call you out mike i was there
to help you out and that's what tom
brady should have had in his headset
right should have had his offensive
coordinator telling him hey we need this
play it's fourth down buddy
but here's the thing mike you owned up
to it tom brady didn't right and that's
what bothered me about what happened
last week tom brady refused to own up to
it and bruce arians
you know after calling him out following
week one and there was the brouhaha in
the aftermath of oh how dare you call
out tom brady aryans defended him and it
just makes me wonder it makes me wonder
what the real reaction from tom brady to
being called out by bruce aaron's after
week one was because arians wasn't going
there at all after everyone knew tom
brady lost track of the downs
ah yeah and that's that's something that
i looked at mike you always find glorio
that's good flora that's something i
looked at too and i was like why don't
tom just admit that like admit it you
know what i'm saying what's the big deal
there's so much stuff going on as a
quarterback people would understand
because you have to keep track of so
many different things going on you got
so many different elements moving and
stuff like that and if i'm tom i just
say you know what i'm i had a brain fart
i just i totally forgot what the play
was and i'll do better next week and i
think the locker room would receive it a
little bit better if you could own up as
a leader of that locker room to the
mistake that you made
that's a great point all right one last
one guys just two sentences here from
each of you
san francisco against the rams tony i'll
let you go first our sunday night game
on nbc
um rams are going to put a lot of
pressure on whoever the quarterback is
if the rams can stop the run it's going
to be a long day for san francisco if
i'm the 49ers i've got to get my running
game going
right me the rams the commitment to the
run um and they have to do a better job
in the secondary in particular at the
linebacker position in the secondary
making open field tackles but i like
what i like what the rams are doing
offensively a lot of commitment to the
run but also robert woods he's their
best offensive player
the rams are the unofficial nfc east
champions they've only beaten teams from
the nfc east the worst division in
football we're going to find out how
good the rams are and we may find out
how bad the 49ers are especially at the
quarterback position
that's the biggest one to me guys you
know we've seen cj beathard come in here
a couple of times
garoppolo wasn't ready they said it but
was it the fact that he wasn't ready
wasn't mobile with the ankle is he
struggling what does kyle shanahan do
and in a division where i know the rams
are the champs of the east but at least
they are four and one and we saw
seattle's resiliency is there they're in
the middle one of those great seattle
type runs
you can't let too many lengths get
between you and the top of the nfc west
really important for san francisco to
figure out their quarterback situation
we'll talk about this on football night
at 7 eastern on sunday night and come
over when the sunday games are done for
all the highlights and then we'll have
the 49ers and the rams gentlemen be safe
be good can't wait to connect on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports